so today about doing special ranges in
Python memory a very very specific topic
I wrote a couple of blog posts about it
out and we actually made it possible to
do all the stuff that memory was to use
of some standard libraries today and you
know what kind of alternatives back on
you when you're facing this issue so
actually it's not the only way to solve
their problem billions of light amidst
billions of options solving this problem
and of course I want you to understand
that when actually produces actually
system it's a CAD code and saturated
Xing yeah so what was the problem here
we are having reverse a couple of
hundred million duplication events every
day we actually want to give this data
some dimensionality some condition
and therefore we be assigned to those
events what interests and what is the
point of the dresses everything can be
our it can be a lead an AGM can be
pretty much anything the park band is
also one of the first apparently we are
still expecting this from mobile speed
Levin had roughly four Germany one point
five six seven billion full of interest
there and now the object is pretty much
for eternity meant get the stop limit
the w5i me the salute about here HT also
polio very nice to be recommended is
actually showing this one now the
certain issue that we are facing is that
you want to get for every event the
digital widget that are within this
range sounds easy
definite sky for a year but it's
actually not easy if you need to do it
millions of times a day
what culture about 23 and when you
definition most of you probably work
with pasta sauce I work with hospice
they have the really amazing thing which
is called
[Applause]
[Music]
who come back development side
especially it's also very neat special
creamy and abilities region as fast
there's also the option so trust me mmm
focus on manga and this is probably what
I want to talk to you about today
because we apparently didn't have the
chance for this juice is 622 thread
there and they also had up to be too
slow as you can see here 100 million of
the stage already reasoning I mean we
have 40 hours data and we should finish
within 40 to the forty hours a day was
not never finished processing the most
with and you need to do every single
review and so many
which looks like somewhere else and now
the magical ingredient to the Central
Asian Indians I mean everyone who
probably did everything basically and
this what we're in was mutual profit
past three time milliseconds areas in
memory as mentioned people who talk this
next part today and when you google
spatial this is pretty much do a basic
chemistry capitalistic of indexes is
that you pretty much want to minimize
the amount of computations what you I
mean if I have two million
part of interests in the nativist of
Corsican heavy requests to take it the
distance to every to everyone this is 2
million calculations that Metacritic and
this doesn't scale this is why you
should organize data this is pretty much
as the name rectangle tree which
organizes all the data points into
rectangular sand structure pretty much
but this when you know I had a crew
which is a rectangle give me another
rectangle can really easily traverse the
street and demonstrate the stand was the
poetry is something that she is since
the data for the spheres
3d also have a record the way and edges
we have you know spectrum Verisign about
yeah
[Music]
and this example the negatives due to
this very nice very cool
stretching the perfect information
because many important relics is it
how does have all spiritual level
we'll check if is your is your spear
apparently in the New York rules if not
that you got in pursuit so then you have
pretty much one person they don't have
no data instead of comparing to moving
different examples which are said to be
okay to take out Linda sphere and go
deeper in the spirit and here to the end
seven comparisons if I'm right to
actually get my data out of us and
comparator to moving this is quite a
bunch of course a lot more a bit deeper
than this one fix you gives you a
picture and now has the deep part which
allows you to use Hansen distance which
is usually used when you compare the
distance of a blow and I mean so a
couple fans of the coat and you are
missing X this is so this also justified
always amazed what a nice piece of
software is especially since it's
awesome okay all be done let's move ugh
who knows about the concept of unitless
maybe picture okay I hope because it's a
really one amazing work especially as
the people grew as spatial data this is
my opinion
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so and then also within the so having
said and then pretty much socially
awkward because you using
a vast distances to victory so far so
good
where to annuities let's your passes or
if I just afternoon wasting my time here
we actually wanna compare also against
baseline so we have all three images
what approach it would be this
calculating every single time the
distance to 2 million animals so this
one actually produced already mix again
[Music]
this is nothing unexpected I mean if
they're only something close to propose
then you would have done something
completely Brown doing that we knew this
see you have a still some kind of
interest growth as the stables and then
single digits so we pretty much achieved
also when we rise and then accordingly
which we need to do something
between one one five three four five
seconds any of the numbers again have
already coming to a conclusion worst
performance having 100 will increase
again
forty 12.1 hours of processing time
which is something you can actually dip
with which you know every day with but
of course never their domiciles now you
need to need to create the cities when
you have both ways to create your most
cos index at once don't need to care
about it we need every time we start our
workers first of all index all the data
that we have and then keep the data in
memory index pretty much a memory this
is cost a lot of memory organization
right but no memory consumption
especially if you used an educator and
watery implementation what I again was
stressed that even though we also talked
today s came to Venice so much many good
functionality can use it for a lot of
different guests as me something
moving in and also what we learned large
aminos
yes it also big data needs on big
problems if you have little process
couple of hundred together today
standard solutions often fake need to
think your way around it and also
something with your database due to some
weird reason it doesn't support any your
spatial indexing features is still named
uses kind of stopped here so we are
presently also use go to California for
some of the sample data processing parts
and then give spatial support and
therefore we visit from my side thank
you very much
[Applause]
you
[Applause]